hi everybody I read 47 books in 2023 we
read so that we can experience other
lives cuz our own life is
so small and
fleeting this is the best book I read in
2023 it is called Old Goro often uh
translated as father Goro or uh
variations on that written by Honore de
Balzac huh Balzac this is just one piece
of his massive human comedy which
contains I don't know how many novels
and short stories I was really surprised
by the immediacy and the relatability of
his characters um this is kind of like a
retelling in a sense not a retelling but
it draw there's similarities to King
Lear in that there's the father and the
ungrateful daughters he was writing at a
time of huge upheaval and a lot of
change uh capitalism driving all sorts
of changes in the hierarchies our main
character we follow ranak is is trying
to figure out how to fit into this world
and you know he's trying to borrow money
from his family so he can continue to
live in this lifestyle in Paris and he
lives in this horrible horrible boarding
house he has to go mingle with all the
fancy French people and try to fit into
High Society so he's just taking all
this money from his family which I guess
he does because he wants to wants to
basically become someone's mistress his
hope is sort of to become some fancy uh
Parisian woman's lover uh basically and
get his own apartment it's just it's so
interesting it is like a tragic story
but there's a lot of humor and just the
details are amazing you read the first
you know 10 pages and just the
description of The Boarding House are
fantastic I mean this is one of bac's
probably most famous and well read books
currently reading cousin bet the
character of Goro is actually he's just
like so doting of a father and just
gives his daughters whatever they want
and he has they're bad daughters but
he's also like not a good father because
it's all from like a a self-serving
place of of trying to always please them
and give them everything they want
because he wants to be a good father it
results in his own poverty and he just
comes across as foolish the last 50
pages are like high melodrama just kind
of Soul crushing it's just fantastic
yeah I love it bzac I mean who knew this
young upand Comer before we get into the
next one I want to talk about
something it's the sponsor of the video
this video is sponsored by hellofresh
Nadia and I actually have used
hellofresh before in the past and really
enjoyed it so I was really happy they
wanted to work with us hellofresh is
here to Kickstart a new year of
nutritious and delicious recipes and to
beat the morning blues with free
breakfast when you join hellofresh
you'll get free breakfast for Life while
your subscription is active we're
talking one delicious breakfast item
packed in your big green hellofresh box
forever now that's something to wake up
early for am I right everyone's trying
to revamp their eating habits in 2024
and let hellofresh be your guy have a
wholesome 2024 with health forward
options like calorie smart and protein
smart recipes I don't know if you guys
know this but Nadia and I don't eat meat
but hellofresh has plenty of meat-free
options the stuff is easy to prepare
it's really good and it tells you how
long it's going to take to make it don't
let recipe bored up keep you from
reaching your goals give hellofresh a
try and choose from 30 plus calorie
smart and protein smart recipes each
week packed with fresh ingredients
everything arrives pre-portioned and
right at your doorstep for less hassle
the easiest cooking experience I've ever
had click the link in the description or
use my code and get free breakfast for
Life One breakfast item per box while
subscriptions active the code to use is
PG MCT free take advantage of some great
meals while you can all right back to
the video next up uh 8 million ways to
die this is a book by Lauren Block it's
part of his Matthew Scutter series I
read this earlier in the year this is I
think the fifth in the series but I feel
like this is the most fleshed out well
developed of the story cop turned a
private detective in New York City
nothing super like revolutionary about
it but I think the tone is very striking
for the time it was written 8 million
ways to die focuses mostly on this
character's alcoholism and it's it's
done in a very realistic way and the
Mystery is fantastic you know Lawrence
block can really like sketch a character
so well in such a concrete language that
it feels like real people you know
you're encountering on in these streets
the last lines of the book were just
like really moving like I I had loved
these Scutter books a lot but it wasn't
until 8 million ways to die when I
thought wow this is actually like a
perfect book it's really really good I
would recommend starting with the sins
of the father but you could probably
just jump in with this one a stab in the
dark is also really good I would like to
talk about a book called the seventh
some of you may know that I've been
diving into the Parker series which is a
classic crime series spanning like 24
books I believe I read gosh probably 19
of them last year they're quick they're
hardboiled they go through the decades
really I mean they were begun in the 60s
and didn't end until the author Donald
weslake passed in 2008 they're
incredible and um I feel like if you
enjoy David vur the killer you would
especially find them interesting cuz
we're following a character who is
supposedly like the toughest meanest
person he's kind of a sociopath at times
in in the series especially in the first
book in the series but he's so committed
to the job to the heist he's a
professional and that's what these books
are all about is about like
professionalism the the worst characters
the bad guys in the series the traitors
the people who mess up the job they're
amateurs anyways I just wanted to pick
one to talk about and I think it's my
favorite I don't know there's a few that
that linger I love when Parker goes on
Revenge mode um you have certain books
that are just following the setup The
Heist the the aftermath like the score
that's a good one but the seventh really
follows the guy who messes up the job
and how Parker has to figure it out and
he come sort of a detective action in
the book is fantastic um we see new
sides of Parker I mean I think what's so
remarkable about the books is that we're
able to stay interested in Parker as a
character when there's not much going on
under the hood you know but we're seeing
him through the eyes of all of these
wonderfully drawn characters the good
guys the bad guys the cops fantastic
stuff in the 7th uh so if you're going
to check out a Parker I would check out
um the score or the seventh and Now for
Something Completely Different Larry MCM
Mery moving mov on I I really enjoy
Larry MCM marter here he wrote Lonesome
Dove uh famously probably his most
famous book The Last Picture Show I
picked an interesting book this is one
of his earlier books I haven't seen many
talk about it long book I mean this my
copy is 830 something pages but pretty
sure a lot of paperbacks are a thousand
and more pages I feel like mcy and
ballzack share similar interests
especially when creating really
believable Rich characters and just
letting the world spin around them and
not worrying so much about plot MCM is
able to make basically a novel about
failure of a marriage into something so
gripping and it drags a little bit in
the middle but the book really should be
called paty Carpenter she's the like the
main character but we get to see other
characters perspectives it's weird
because it feels like nothing happens in
the book but also so much does I was
debating whether to finish this book
because it was taking so long I think I
started it in like September and I
finished it in December I kept coming
back to it because the pros is so clean
and MCM marry has so so many great
little insights and is just so such a
good Observer of human nature things he
picks up on in relationships in the way
characters are thinking and feeling so
precise and you just go like man he must
know somebody these must be real people
because they feel so real you know
they're not remarkable characters you
know at one point in the book after all
the drama happens our lead character
she's reading Anna kenina and is going
like wow this is really high drama this
is someone's life like what what is my
life even like what is huge and
emotional about my life that I've been
treating it as such and eventually I got
into the groove that the point of the
book was that there isn't much that's
happening that a lot of people are kind
of stuck in their own ways a lot of the
biggest changes in our lives happen when
we aren't even paying attention um and
it's slow and things just move on and
and slip into new phases you never you
feel like the characters are dragging
McMurtry along and it's never the
opposite it never feels like MC merch is
going well we need this character to do
this no they're they're their own
entities they're their own things that's
why I feel like it's so much in the vein
of like 19th century novelists and I
think it's funny sometimes when people
compare Larry McMurry to Cormac McCarthy
just because they wrote about the
Southwest or wrote westerns sometimes uh
they couldn't be more different first
off McMurtry wrote great female
characters I don't know if McCarthy ever
did but and while I love Cormac McCarthy
you know especially just from a Pros
level uh MCM is totally different
completely accessible descri describing
the interior lives of his character it's
so precise so realistic he just has an
ability to get inside someone's not even
their brain but just their their gut if
you're a little daunted by a book of
this length and you want something
similar check out all my friends are
going to be strangers which is an
unofficial sequel to this but is sort of
like a prequel a little overlap you
could read it and there's some similar
themes uh but it's about like a young
writer um but it's much shorter so you
could read that and see if you know dip
your toes in the water uh anyways highly
recommend moving on time to move on
finally I couldn't talk about my
favorite books of 2023 without
mentioning John D McDonald I mean a lot
has been written about but I feel like
he's fallen out of favor somewhat in
popularity mostly because of sexism
that's common in in a lot of his books
uh unfortunately but he was a great pulp
uh writer he wrote tons of really
fantastic novels uh you know in the 50s
and 60s before hitting it big with the
Travis McGee series Travis McGee I'm a
little iffy on right now um I enjoyed
the first book but there is issues of
Just Like Old Man yelling at Cloud
syndrome I love his Pros I love his
ability to get into characters heads he
was able to like do a lot of different
kinds of things so Bordertown girl I'm
picking this just as an example of a
great one to read it's actually two
novellas the first Nolla which is called
Bordertown girl reads more like a um
reads more like a script like an action
uh like script about um you know man on
the Run
um CD criminal stuff going on sort of
action-packed there's a lot going on and
there's less of that like internal
Nuance it's fun it's like a fun read but
it's more plot heavy and less internal
the second one though is called Linda
and man Linda is just an incredible Noir
story a man and a wife and a murder and
their friends uh I don't want to reveal
anything but it's just the perfect kind
of hard boil story Double Indemnity type
of tale that uh is so heartbreaking and
ruthless fantastically described damn
wow how is this not a movie you know
some John D McDonald uh stories have
been made into movies uh most notably
Cape Fear originally titled the
executioners that's in an okay book read
this read Bordertown girl and Linda
anyways I want to thank everyone for
making 2023 an amazing year I don't talk
about books as much as I used to but
it's still my passion and I'm never
going to quit it was actually an amazing
year for reading this year and I'm
really grateful to everyone who reached
out and who still wants to chat about
books really means a lot anyways what
are your favorite books that you read is
there anything that you think I should
read thank you everyone I hope you have
a splendid
2024 good luck take care bye-bye